hey what's up welcome back to another
episode of visual effects artists react
today is a very special one because
we've got Todd vizier here on the couch
today Todd is a current ilm employee
he's been working there for like 22
years he's worked on almost every single
movie that you've loved
[Music]
the helicopter was actually there
helicopter's actually there so wow
that's a lot of elements we're gonna
have some great stories today everything
behind the soldiers is synthetic at this
point it's so cool very happy to uh
continue to hopefully Inspire the Next
Generation the way I was inspired by the
folks ahead of me
wait how did the camera get behind his
face
[Music]
how did the camera do this every iconic
shot of like the past 20 years is you
[Music]
Mission Impossible welcome back brother
Mii
that was a perfect case the camera shot
hold on you said that perfect case to
camera shot yeah sorry all right sorry
go ahead if you ever make it come with
me one shot you'll probably have to do
where somebody's gonna drop something or
slide something and it needs to land in
just the right spot you need to pull
focus and you're going to quickly
discover that that's the hardest shot
you ever have to get in your entire
project
and so I just I caught it here because
that case oh just it slides perfectly
right into frame it stops it's in Focus
like that's like a 300 take shot
potentially but what I'm gathering here
is that that's a CGI case
it's a real case but it's a visual
affection
I get it
to move just the right way and to have
it framed the right way I had to splice
together various takes and put them
together oh really it's a visual
effects
shot that hopefully nobody's even
thinking of no one I guarantee you no
one has thought about that case shot
being an effect shot yeah but I have to
see the artistry
oh boom oh yeah iconic that was in every
single trailer again yet never tell me
that this is going to be a big part of
your marketing because I do not need
that added pressure and thankfully I
only realized that after we final the
shot
this is probably like 10 or 12 major
pieces of Photography that we put
together Brian Cantwell was our layout
supervisor on this one and we were like
how are we going to do this it's uh the
camera's on the dolly moving backwards
and all the multiple passes were filmed
with the grips doing their best to mimic
the last pass they did with Tom Tom was
the Bible of the shot he was on wires
right it was on wires and he got moved
it is a stunt that a seasoned stunt
performer would be extremely proud of
and then the full-scale explosion of the
car back there it was another element
there was the car on the right whose
windshield explodes and then there were
other elements as well so it was very
difficult to put all the stuff together
and make it a cohesive camera move so oh
the helicopter was actually there
helicopter's actually there so close it
right there and feel my pain oh no wow
that's a lot of elements so they built a
stereo camera rig with overlap
so that we can basically have two motion
picture cameras going at the same time
so I would have two pieces of negative
to work with okay which is wonderful
it's great for Fidelity these also have
to get now seamed together and and if
you look carefully Tom goes across the
seam oh my God I didn't know and the
explosion goes across the scene you can
see the dolly tracks you can see the
sandbags you can see the pads and
everything like that so uh this was a
real tricky shot to put together these
look like a nightmare I'm really glad
that you noticed the suitcase in that
shop yeah yeah because it gets kicked up
by the explosion because a grip on set
puppeteered that suitcase and I had a
rod and a bunch of wires going down on
it and he just kind of went okay three
two one boom any kind of Puppeteer and
then I added all the dust and all the
thing I I extended his movement but
having that perspective change on the
suitcase it makes for a better shot yeah
it's crazy they filmed basically two
angle like two cameras to give you the
widescreen yeah because in this day and
age you just like oh just grab your 12K
digital camera right
different story now oh and and if you
look at this in the trailer that the
timing on the trailer was slightly
different they wanted a UAV to go fly by
earlier so I had to make a special
trailer version of this shot because it
was cut way shorter or his eye patch
it's it's it's hard
and then your scripts get all messed up
wait was just the trailer version or I
did this thing for the trailer I wanted
to use it for the final yeah stuff like
that if you thought what Tom Cruise does
is dangerous just take a look at your
own diet Dean I'm talking to you put
away the taquitos you think you're
getting your nutrition from that well
yeah it's got like cheese oh cover all
your bases with today's sponsor hg1 ag1
is a daily foundational nutrition
supplement that supports whole body
Health dude prebiotics probiotics and
plant-based enzymes help support
digestion regularity and overall gut
health look at this D3 plus K2 have you
even heard of that before oh dude I
think taquitos all day there's so much
you don't have in you oh my god open up
legitimately I do this every morning do
you really me and my wife do this every
single morning here you go oh who's
hungry
okay great look at that now you
two is taken care of for the day and
look at the sheer quantity of
supplements that are involved in this
you're getting 467 of your vitamin C and
what's amazing is it's such a fine
powder that you don't even need a mixer
of any kind you just pour it in with
some water shake it up and it's done so
you do this every morning this is how I
start my morning and honestly it tastes
great too I promise what do you think
honest reaction
that's actually really good I know right
it's genuinely surprising you want to
start with having a good diet but this
is going to support everything you're
doing yeah you know and honestly when
you make the right choice at the
beginning of the day it weirdly makes
the rest of the choices throughout the
day easier because you're already off to
a good start so put away the taquitos
weird breakfast choice you know what
after drinking this I don't want those
potatoes anymore Maybe
we're healing people baby it's the AG
one way this guy's so excited he's alive
again dude I genuinely feel I know I'm
telling you it's legit this is nothing
like that seriously Taquito Dean is dead
but if you use the link down in the
description down below you get a free
year supply of that sweet vitamin D3 K2
five to-go packets you get this sweet
container for all your powdery greeny
needs and the bottle that athletic Dean
is holding right now all of this is free
with your first purchase if you use the
link in the description down below now
let's get back to react
all right
this is this is the first time I saw CGI
that was like right in front of my face
that was photorealistically perfect
yeah this sequence is so awesome is that
you I'm here to make Miranda happy
every iconic shot of like the past 20
years is you
oh my God I think that's what I said
when I got turned over the shot how am I
going to do this now you want to talk
about a magic trick here this is a plate
based shot that helicopter is there I
was about to say for the first half of
the shot except for the rotors on top we
were completely replace that when we
Dolly across that hummer and get
revealed
everything behind the soldiers is
synthetic wow it's so cool because I'm
like I want to keep as much of the
photography as possible so that's all my
synthetic stuff that's insane
so much work all the volumetrics I had
to do myself because we wanted to have
this end be Smoky and weird with all the
muzzle flashes and all the firing going
on all the signature anamorphic Michael
Bay flares had to sit there and it'd be
real but they could not obscure the very
expensive animation that Scott benza and
kg Yamaguchi did uh Jeff greeby lit this
David histanaga did some effects all the
spark events I laid out in After Effects
the ones that are hitting the ground are
stage elements okay right there's like
some cheaty Reflections in there they're
really cheese ball and then those guys
are those soldiers are just still frames
in the background there yeah
they're just yeah like this but the
muzzle flashes listen they are soldiers
they know what to do no flinching
transforming helicopter means nothing to
them the most unflinching of soldiers
yeah yeah that's the first one we did
and when we got this one done we were
like okay I think we could do this movie
[Music]
Beth D'Amato was in charge of paint and
Roto on this movie and she did an
amazing job
oh let's go there's from one Banger to
the next the vast majority of the movies
official effects were done by WETA
effects down in New Zealand incredible
job all the creatures and stuff like
that when things are getting near the
end of production frame store and
industrial Light and Magic were brought
in to handle uh shots like this these
these vehicle shots
the first shot I ever did in Nuke is
there no Union here for them flying that
close together
[Laughter]
it's a very long lens when you when you
see your lung lenses it compresses but
again it's a movie and you do some
really fun stuff in movies John Knoll
was at the helm Jim and John go way back
they have a language all their own they
communicate on the same level uh this is
yeah this is a video game wall renders
against the raw faces okay wow
so it's like all right you imported the
render you imported the background and
you hit play for the first time you're
like time to do my work this is so
inspiring because in a way it's so
approachable here's your Unreal Engine
render so right I mean
it's amazing it's beautiful it feels big
it's the temperatures but it does look
like a really high-end video game render
until all the lens and the phase and the
fog and the you know secondary emotions
like now it's like now it's life and not
trying to Discount the 3D animation like
it's amazing I want the most beautiful
renders that I hardly have to do
anything on please give me the most
beautiful run vendors yeah this is the
god rays and the volumetrics we did I
did it in the comp to have the most of
control so you see these extremely
subtle not God Rays anti-crepusscular
Rays as Jim Cameron would correct us on
uh anti-carpuscular Rays where you're
occluding light in an environment with
lit atmosphere this is effectively all
the Shadows yeah the shadows in the air
around the vehicles that's right so cool
so cool so you're seeing the soot you're
seeing the heat Distortion you're seeing
the glows and the flares I believe
Yannick daso did the background here
which is a bunch of paintings tomfy just
did the lighting on all the ships put
all that together with some flares and
some glaring and well what's what's
really great is that later John Knoll
told me after we finally he's like that
was some really good looking heat Ripple
it's probably the best we've ever done
at Island I'm just like
[Laughter]
mission accomplished oh my gosh is this
really happening right now
remember blue is blue and when it's red
dead all right so now we're taking a
look at Mission Impossible 4 the
protocols of ghost this was my first
movie as compositing supervisor oh it
was an incredible thrill to be asked to
come through this movie for John Knoll
and Brad Bird who is one of my heroes
is this a real shot this is one
photography okay this is photography
with a massive amount of manipulation to
allow Tom Cruise to do this stunt safely
where are the wires holding him up are
they going up to the left side of him
and Crossing across his hair yeah um
they're they're they're filling frame
here on the screen right yeah I'm just
looking at all these places where there
have to be wires but we don't see them
right and also navigating where the
camera is going so that it doesn't
actually hit the wire
a sequence like this it's like okay well
great wires wires against his face wires
against his costume against his hair and
against the skyline okay and the Chrome
reflection yeah those reflect and you
know what those areas reflect the other
areas that are reflecting and then
you've got the mirror of this and it's
not a perfect mirror it's like a Double
Image because you're seeing a reflection
of the face of the mirror and you see it
on his hand there there's like a double
layer there so he's just
long shot right it's an extraordinary
achievement on all levels from a shot
design standpoint from a performer from
rigging lighting camera visual effects
Trevor Hazel was in charge of paint Roto
for this this also required a lot of
compositing this was the shot was done
by Jen Howard did an amazing job what
the hell is that
foreign
I composited 20 quadrillion ants into
this shot long story
wait how did the camera get behind his
face
how did the camera do this this is sweet
oh my God I did
sequence and I never thought about
there's a window that camera moved
through so this is on a partial set
piece in Vancouver he's 20 feet off the
ground and some of the sky is the real
Vancouver Sky on the flip side is a blue
screen we are looking at the beginning
of the shot into the set piece of the
reflective window into a blue screen so
that's all synthetic back there mark
Nettleton did an amazing job on this
shot as the camera swings around the
window is removed oh so that the camera
can swing around and get an over the
shoulder of time wow so that's a real
reflection right there it's not a that's
a real reflection of Tom
but not of Dubai okay because we're in
Vancouver that's where the camera is you
know how you you do that stuff you get
really talented artists like Mark
Nettleton to do them for you
and we killed this shot You Ain't Seen
Nothing Yet
so another movie that Brad Bird directed
is Tomorrowland and you worked on this
one quite a bit as well right right
that's right I heard that this was the
hardest shot you ever had to do honestly
they're all hard they're all hard
but the most complicated was probably
this one coming up
[Music]
check me out well
so a complicated shot there's a lot of
elements and it broke our brains uh
particularly from a layout point of view
and environments the thing about that
shot is that it's the boy he's on a
turntable he's flat footed he's just
standing and there's a grip kind of
moving him around he's being filmed with
two cameras simultaneously oh to get
like the angle on the opposite side of
the window right there's another camera
that's getting his reaction his
reflection so from a layout point of
view the first thing of course you have
to do is flop that image it also means
you have to match move both images
because we are attach cameras moving
camera's moving boys moving the the
camera in the boy are moving slightly
differently in the in the plates then we
have to project him into the reflection
we have to put CG thrusters and stuff
underneath him from his jeans down
that's CG everything we do in the
foreground has to be similar to the
background in addition he's wearing a
leather jacket but he's moving it
incredible speeds we need to make the
jacket ruffle it was not ruffling on set
so we have to add this little Distortion
so is that like a 2d Distortion that's a
2d Distortion and dialing it just right
was so hard
when he emerges and we see the city in
the background your eye is to go to the
gorgeous amazing utopian environment of
Tomorrowland and we missed a little
slide of ham in the pork and you miss
the fact that I used him going into the
sun to wipe on a fully digital double of
him
and using the light it was the perfect
split line what I love is that like when
he pops out it's literally just a cut
like it looks like it's just it's like a
three-throwing is it a three frame okay
but it works so well you don't even
notice because the new light comes in it
would look different anyway and your
brain just accepts that it's a new thing
but it's the same kid
but it also shows you how incredibly
accurate our match move and matchmation
had to be because if you look directly
at the jetpack or his helmet or whatever
that all that stuff has to match then we
had the interesting problem of rendering
the the leather jacket well do we do a
wind simulation on that oh yeah or will
it just keep doing the same horrible or
will it look weird next to the 2D
wearable so we did a 2d warble on the CT
jacket yeah
yeah you probably shouldn't do but we
did it for continuity of yeah I really
wanted the camera shake to feel like if
the wind forces were different when they
were right next to the building and then
they emerged into a let's say a
different pressure system you know the
camera recovers that's I was I tried to
build that in there that's really nice
it's cool balancing there's a lot of fun
ingredients on the shot so Enrico Dam
that was the environment artist on this
one he did such an incredible job gave
me tons and tons of passes so we asked
for people to leave comments usually
it's suggesting a scene or a movie or
something like that I would love some
comments for guests that you would like
to have in the show people you'd like to
see joining us on the couch to talk to
Todd uh where can we uh hear more about
what you want to talk about with movies
uh go to my website everything's there
at tfizeri.com our ilm website is
amazing ilm.com tons of film history
there and just watch a lot of movies
folks just watch a lot of movies they're
great and thanks for watching I'll see
you next week